morning if you would join me in uh we're
Allegiance I pledge aliance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
nation
harmony with that I'll open the continue
public hearings on B reform this morning
I understand we have some folks here
from the county and I would uh invite
them to come up to the mic
first morning if you would introduce
yourselves and tell us um all you have
to tell us about baale
count one of the things that we had
talked about that we thought might be
helpful is just sort of talking about
the background of what happens when you
get
arrested um essentially
there's there's a couple different ways
to get arrested If you're sort of caught
red-handed the police can take you into
custody or they police May apply for an
arrest warrant take you in a custody on
the warrant but once you're arrested and
you're brought back to the police
station they go through a booking
process during that process um the
police are obligated to call a bail
commissioner there's a a statute in New
Hampshire which requires the police to
to notify a bail commissioner and notify
a a arreste that they have the right to
a bail commissioner
the bail commissioner is supposed to
respond to the police department and
essentially sets bail on the arreste the
bail commissioner has a couple of
choices they can set preventative
detention they can set cash bail or they
can release the person on personal
recognizance the if a person is held
meaning either held on preventative
detention or held on cash bail they're
entitled to a hearing within 24 hours
except weekends in front of a judge
where a judge would decide bail or
whether or not bail is appropriate and
at that hearing the complaints would
have been filed already in the court
there'd be a prosecutor there and
potentially a defense
attorney if the person's released on
personal recognizance bail the bail
commissioner gives the arreste an
arraignment date there's one of the
rules of criminal procedure indicates
that that arraignment date shall be no
sooner than 35 days from the date of
arrest so if you're arrested October 1st
your arraignment date is going to be at
least November 6 and can be further out
than
that if personal recognizance bail is
set what ends up happening is the police
department then transfers that paperwork
to the prosecutor's office or files the
complaints in court there's a rule that
says the complaints have to be filed no
more than 14 or no less than 14 days
prior to arraignment so again in that
October 1 scenario we would be filing
the
complaints no less than 14 days before
that November 6
arraignment what that means is that
there's a a gap in time often between if
a bail commissioner releases someone on
personal recognizance bail and when that
case is actually received and reviewed
by a
prosecutor um there are
certainly Provisions in the statute that
IND indicate if the state feels that
personal recognizance bail was
inappropriately set we can file a motion
to have that bail reviewed by the court
the the statute indicates that review
should happen within I believe it's 48
Hours the the difficulty is that there's
already that Gap that's occurred within
those 35 days so we're not immediately
hearing about the pr Veil
usually
um once the person is arraigned in court
on their regular arraignment the court
can modify bail I would indicate that
that at least in my experience has been
very seldom will the court modify bail
at a at a normal arraignment people can
file motions for for bail review the
defense can file a motion for bail
review the state can file a motion for
bail review again it's been my
experience that if the defense files a
motion to have bail reviewed that's
generally held within 24 hours um my
experience as the state has been that
when I filed motions for bail review
it's been significantly longer to get
them scheduled than 24 hours um so
that's sort of the the background of of
where you start if if I may to Jack yeah
one of the ideas we've contemplated is
giving the prosecutors the ability to
appeal and the defendant on certain
limited enumerated um crimes be held
pending that appeal um if it's in the
Circuit Court to the superior court and
that seems pretty clearcut the question
I have is how often are these already in
the superior court and
um what would then be the Avenue of
appeal all that's left to the Supreme
Court which would clog their calendar
insignificantly so there's already a
statute that allows the prosecutor to
appeal a bill commissioner's decision
whether it's in circuit court or
Superior Court I me the judge's decision
so you'd appeal the judge's decision to
so at arraignment or at the first
appearance the judge doesn't modify PR
bail and the and the prosecutor objects
yeah um Expediting that appeal to no
more than 48 hours to Superior Court and
the defendant beh
held you could what were your thoughts
on
that I don't see a problem with that
necessarily other than would you be
having super Superior Court
judges for lack of a better term second
guessing other Superior Court judges
that was my question if if it started in
so with the end of felonies first more
of your arraignments are going to ur cir
circuit course so that would
significantly imp impact that but how
many do start in spor court right now
all felonies start in Superior Court
right so the the superior the felony
level bail prior to felony first being
um eliminated starts in Superior Court
so you'd have you have Superior Court
judges in the first instance setting
those
bailes in terms of having an appeal to
the Supreme Court there's there's
already a statute 5976 that talks about
an appeal to the Supreme Court it says
it shall be determined
promptly I think that promptly to the
Supreme Court means something different
than promptly to most other people as
soon as we can maybe um I know that the
the case up in uh Coos County where the
individual had hit the
motorcyclists had appealed his bail to
Supreme Court and I think that that
appeal was resolved in a like four to
six month period which I think may be
prompt for the Supreme Court but
certainly doesn't meet the
colloquial
prompt and there's a there's a question
too is if you have a appeal to to a
suprem circuit court order within 48
hours that there be an evidentiary
hearing um that requires
Witnesses I think each side if that's
the
issue may or may not have difficulty
getting appropriate witnesses there
within 48 Hours well again with the end
of felonies first I'm foreseeing
hopefully within within the year the the
arrangements in the first instance even
for felonies would begin in the circuit
court again so it would be an appeal to
the Su um to the uh Superior Court which
would be much more doable and reasonable
and as I indicated 59760 already has
that process in place but it doesn't
have the hold in place like you said and
that would be only in an extremely
limited series I mean it wouldn't be
able to request it on every case but in
limited number of cases that were
violent or danger to the public that the
um the prosecuting attorney could say we
just don't agree your honoring we'd like
it to be
reviewed so barring getting into the
Quagmire of the Supreme Court it's it's
certainly a doable idea then you would
it help the state in keeping more people
off of the street and probably shouldn't
be
then potentially I that's why I ask as
I'm I'm thinking through what you're
saying as you're saying it
um I think you could certainly have a
statute that stays the decision of the
Circuit Court pending the appeal so if
the person was held and the circuit
court judge said personal recognizance
bail you could appeal that and stay that
personal recognizance bail pending the
appeal I think it becomes more
problematic to say that the person's
held pending an appeal when they were
free when they were free um because you
could certainly have a situation where a
person is granted PR bail by the bail
commissioner comes into court is granted
PR bail by the judge and then having the
state say we're going to appeal that
having them automatically held I think
could be potentially problematic and to
along that same line granting the
ability of the police to appeal a bail
commissioner's decision likewise with a
very limited set of criminal where they
would be held yeah um but within the
same 24 hours except for requiring the
court to hold hearings over the weekend
um so that it wouldn't make them stay
over the weekend maybe I misunderstood
what you just said but if they're held
with they're in front of a judge the
next day any unless it's a weekend right
what I'm contemplating is requiring the
courts to hold some type of a bear
review over the weekend the question is
would that would that trigger the full
panoply in other words would they get a
defense Council would they get Witnesses
or could it just be a simple review of a
bail commissioner's
parte I I don't think you could
necessarily do it expart I think you
could have a review of the Bill
commissioner's
decision um within 24 hours even on
weekends the the sort of
practical difficulty with that is we
don't work on weekends tends to be the
the the difficulty is um you know we
were talking earlier that prosecutors
tend to be salaried judges tend to be
salaried um I think you'd potentially
have to have that be an open hearing
hearing a public hearing which means
you'd have to have it in a courthouse
with court security where the public was
allowed to attend I I would question so
I and I know this it's a different state
but it still falls under the same um
constitutional rights overall I know in
Massachusetts they have something called
the Jenkins rule where if someone's to
be held more than 24 hours a judge
telephonically speaks with the police as
a review and and all those um other
hearing rights aren't triggered and I
think in that case you you'd essentially
be having the judge setting bail indeed
yeah right in Li of uh if the police
objected to propos personal recognizance
the police said well we would like the
judge to do it yeah um and that may
which would eleviate the second concern
of having to take someone into custody
at court who was already free right no
have again the status quo in place which
is that the person is in custody and
then have an on call Judge review that
bail decision or set bail because we
already have judges issuing emergency U
protection orders over the weekend if a
judge were to say okay every Saturday
morning I'll hold bail hearings for two
hours or or whatever they end up working
out and I do plan obviously to speak
with the Supreme Court Justice about
this but it's it's just ideas that are
bouncing around yeah I think there's a
difference between the initial um
imposition of bail by a by a judge
versus an appeal by a judge and um I
going back a little bit to your question
about um uh doing it exp parte uh I I
don't think that's a good idea uh
frankly I think it's a bad idea because
it it um it stops the accountability of
the individual who's setting the bail
which I think is needs to be open and
and and clear to to Outsiders someone
who's not involved in the process should
be able watch that process uh and um uh
that's the main the main concern that I
have it should be open and clear for the
continuity but if it's in lie of the
bail commissioner if it's initial
setting I think it's a it's a it's a
it's a difference okay because the
initial setting you're able to appeal in
front of a judge in which case it would
be it would be in open court during Open
Session uh the initial setting at a bail
may be at 11: at night um and uh it it
would be appealed to the next or
reviewed in the next session however and
again this would be extremely limited
set of crimes and it may be a
distinction without a difference in
terms of X parte because when the bail
commissioner is there generally the
defendant is going to be sitting in
front of them and the police are going
to be there as well so okay but a right
to councel hasn't yet attached is the
question there is no right to counsel
before the bail commissioner just
because one is a judge versus a there is
no the council until the complaint is
filed there we go thank you please go on
I didn't mean to interrupt if I threw
you off track I
Apologize have anything else I I mean I
have nothing else I'm happy to answer
questions or well one of the concerns
that we've discussed is you know um in
in the Senate Bill the one of the ones
that we're contemplating here they have
a list of 13 crimes I'm sure you're
familiar with it it's our impression
that it's not those 13 crimes that are
driving the public consternation with
the bail situation it's the repeated uh
nuisance crimes it's the trespass it's
the shoplifting it's a disorderly person
that are occurring while people are on
bail again and
again what are your your information can
you give us about that well and I think
another part of their frustration with
the bail system is non- appearances in
court um in Marram County Superior Court
everyone who's arrested released on
personal recognizance bail is given an
arraignment date for their felony those
arraignments occur on Thursday afternoon
so yesterday we had an arraignment
session there were 13 cases scheduled
for arraignment yesterday out of those
cases uh four of those individuals had
obtained counsel so the four individuals
that had obtained Council three of them
waved their arraignment one continued
their arraignment which leaves nine of
those 13
cases and and we could play any guesses
on how many people actually showed up of
the nine of the nine
one so we had one person show up for
their arraignment and eight failures to
appear yesterday all bench warrants
issue yes on felony level PR fails and I
think
that's that's a frustration hopefully
event war chch did the judge did the
judge that you know of set um conditions
if they were picked up on the warrant so
we would request bench warrants with um
no Bail no
bail so theoretically when they're
picked up they'd be a hearing in front
of a judge within 24 hours to set
conditions of bail and set bail um the
frustration is that a lot of those
people get picked up and get released
again on personal recognizance bail or
get released on you know bail with with
conditions and we may find out that
they're violating the conditions of bail
and file a motion to revoke bail and and
the frustration again becomes that those
motions aren't necessarily heard in a
timely fashion um it may take I've
certainly had the experience where the
court holds the motion for 10 days to
wait for defense Council to respond and
then by the time the judge gets it it's
10 days old and the judge says well
we'll we'll schedule a hearing and I may
get a hearing 30 45 days out to revoke
bail to revoke bail so and inevitably
the defendant doesn't show up at their
motion to revoke bail hearing and we get
a no bail bench warrant
um how often is no bail set on the bench
warrants for failure to appear fairly
often um we do have a lot of bench
warrants with with no bail set um and I
think that
that's in my experience and correct me
if I'm wrong I think that's almost the
default for our Superior Court judges at
least in marrat county that their
feeling is you have to go in front of a
judge since a bench has been issued and
you may get PR as a result of that
hearing but initially you're going to be
held no bail pending that least the
warrant's going to issue for no bail um
I I would point out that that the
attorneys in the office if they get a
call if the person doesn't show up no
one knows where is where that person is
um and a Nobel warrant issues by the
court uh if something happens two three
four five days later defense attorney
calls the uh involved prosecutor and
says hey I found out what what happened
and they and they have a a valid reason
for it uh the attorneys in the office
are are pretty flexible about agreeing
to reschedule to vacate a warrant and to
reschedule if there's a reason um but uh
I think Steve's right that the the vast
majority the initiation are a are a hold
or cash one if you could how how often
um do you does it come to your attention
that these defendants are are homeless
they don't have an address
um it's fairly common frequent yeah
matter of fact I just got I saw a
spreadsheet the other day from conquer
Police Department that talked about um
the uh frequency of of arrest on new
charges breach of bail and U failures to
appear um on benchmarks um for uh folks
that don't have a a have more of a fluid
address they don't have a static address
and um the numbers I saw covered I Ted
them up last night from January 1st of
22 to August 16th um there were several
hundred entries but there were 113 bench
warrants between January and middle of
August um and my interpretation of the
spreadsheet was those bench warrants
were not new warrants for new arrest
there were bench Wars for not appearance
in in courts uh and there were 39
breaches of bail for non compliance with
the court orders now there may be some
overlap with those numbers um but those
are the uh those are the numbers from
Just One Police Department in uh in um
in the
county the other thing I I also did a
quick
email to the attorneys before I came
today uh last couple days I got some
responses about how the their request
for warrants and requests for um uh
revocation of bails being processed by
the superior court and um I can give you
a couple examples just just um the
feedback I got back um one individual
five open cases seven failur to appear
uh and um the the concern there is case
of seven failures to appear um a motion
to revoke was filed on five failures to
appear um one person from a 2020 case
had a cash bail issued of $1,000 that
was posted after failures to appear the
uh the state uh did a motion with the
court to Forfeit
the, uh back in April of 2023 we've yet
to have that scheduled Court's not been
not been scheduling that um in uh in
distri Court uh after four failures to
appear $300 cash bail warrant was issued
but again the judge held that for 10
days I I assume uh in keeping with what
Steve mentioned a moment ago that was
probably time for defense Council to get
information about the individual one
attorney filed a motion to revoke in
June filed it electronically it was
filed on June 22nd it was not accepted
by the court till July
18th almost a month accepted they file
electronically court has to accept it
prior to that movement along within the
court system so even acknowledging that
they received the the electronic filing
took a month they they didn't
acknowledge that for just shy of a month
um uh another individual dating back to
2020 failed to appear back in 2020
picked up on the August uh I mentioned
him the guy
from non appearance out of state uh
motion to revoke baale had got awall
from pre-trial Services another attorney
is seven motions for Action without uh
checking with pre-trial Services
whereabouts are unknown um from my
perspective talking with the attorneys
there appears to be a big continuity
issue with the judges and the courts how
fast they accept it how fast they
schedule it going back to what attorney
endress mentioned a moment ago um
defense attorneys file a motion to
review bail they get 24 48 Hours one or
two days it's in front of a judge uh the
state files a motion to revoke a motion
to amend we won't see a notice for that
maybe for or a court schedule two weeks
two and a half weeks if if they even
accept the the uh pleading in a timely
manner um there's no continuity and uh I
think that the system in my opinion
system works generally well the way it's
set up but there's a lot of loose ends
in the system that public policy-wise
need to be need to be tightened up so
what I'm hearing so far isn't
necessarily any kind of repudiation of
the bail statutes themselves as much as
the way the system interacts within
within its own pieces and and I think
that's true I as why I I don't think the
bail statute is fundamentally flawed as
it's written I think it's got a lot of
good stuff in it the the difficulty is
that there's a lot of discretion along
that road um and that's what we'd like
to maybe do is fine-tune not right one
of the one of the things that always
sort of struck me was that there's a
massive amount of training required to
become a police officer in the state of
New Hampshire they go through the
academy they go through field training
so you have very highly trained police
officers in terms of becoming a judge I
don't think there's any requirements but
you get appointed by the governor I
think all the judges in New Hampshire at
this point are attorneys you have highly
experienced intelligent judges you have
highly experienced intelligent
prosecutors
and what always struck me as odd among
that system is the person who decides
whether you go home at night after
you've been arrested is the bail
commissioner and the educational
requirements for bail Commissioners in
the statute are a yearly meeting and a
bail commissioner handbook there's
there's
no there's no 100 hours of training
there's no there's no educational
requirements there and I'm not saying
that the bail Commissioners aren't
trying to do good job or doing a good
job but there's there's a huge amount of
discretion there and you have people
from various backgrounds I know
throughout my career as a prosecutor
there was a time when most bail
Commissioners were retired police
officers um that's changed and there was
a time when most bail Commissioners were
Court Personnel who had been appointed
to be bail
Commissioners so there's there's a wide
variety of people who are in that
role and I think that they're given an
incredible amount of
discretion with very little sort of
objective criteria to say uh you know
here's a a form or here's something to
consider in terms of if you get so many
points you're held or you're not held
yeah and to their credit the bill
Commissioners themselves have asked for
more training and more continuity in
their training um and and we are taking
that very seriously as well
but also you mentioned that many bail
decisions of the Commissioners aren't
being overturned so we can at least
assume arguendo that the decision was
correct or at least not so far off the
bounds that it cried out for reversal
and and I don't disagree with that and I
it's it's sort of a cyclical thing where
what ends up happening is if a bail
commissioner sets personal recognizance
bail like I was saying there's this
there's this lag between when I get it
as a prosecutor if I file a motion
saying the commissioner got this totally
wrong and I end up in front of the judge
and the defendant appears the argument's
going to be he's been good he's been
right he's been good for 30 days and
he's here now yeah obviously PR was the
so it's in the one time it wasn't the
correct decision it's the one time or
the two times it's and I think that
there's different between the person
who's released on personal recognizance
bail and commits further crime and the
difference between the person who's
released on personal recognizance bail
and doesn't come to court because you
know for lack of a better term their
life is a mess and getting somewhere on
a day they're supposed to be there is
virtually an impossibility for that
person well that that brings us back to
the original well the two original
you're held because you're a danger or
because you're a Flight Risk if you
don't show up you're a Flight Risk if
you repeatedly don't show up corre and
if you are but the question becomes then
the danger on one level we discuss
danger as in you know are they going to
hurt somebody but the continued breach
of the public peace in my mind is also
on on a certain level of danger if they
keep getting arrested for shoplifting if
they keep trespassing it eats police
resources it eats Court resources um it
puts police in danger every time they
have to take someone in custody so the
the question is how do we how do we and
I don't mean to put you on the spot yeah
but if any suggestions from you who are
in the trenches would be greatly
appreciated on how we could fine-tune
that yeah I I agree with you that I
think multiple faes to appear does put
you in in danger I think that there's a
certain level of sort of personal
debilitation that comes with um being
arrested multiple times and I think this
sort of overlaps too in a little bit of
like the the mental health system them
but we have people who you know fail to
appear keep committing crimes get
arrested end up being held in jail and
that's the argument that they're a
danger to themselves because they
essentially can't live harmoniously in
society as as we've established it um I
don't know where that line is where you
be you've become a danger from multiple
failures to appear but but I I've
certainly made that argument in the past
um the what about Services because as we
we've established or I believe the
record has established that the majority
of people that are picked up like that
are in need of service either substance
or mental health no doubt doubt so what
what what is available I heard you
mention pre- Services could you tell the
committee what that is and what what's
involved with that so in in Marram
County we have a pre-trial services
program where
you you're subject to essentially
pre-trial monitoring for it's almost
like a pre-trial probation for lack of a
better
term
um there are there are components to
pre-trial Services you have to check in
those check-ins at this point I believe
are
telephonic um there was a time when
pre-trial Services would do home visits
I don't believe they're doing those
anymore that's stopped around Co time
yeah any plans to take it back up um I I
think there is but within marac County
the pre-trial Services folks used to be
uh sworn deputies the pre-trial Services
changed their wiring diagram within the
county um and I think they're going
through the certification now through I
want to say Corrections U because the
concern is that that if they go to
someone's house you know we're dealing
with individuals
who are in front of the criminal justice
system and that may not be receptive to
having someone coming to their home and
um having a single person who's unarmed
going to A A Home of someone who doesn't
want them there uh may be problematic so
I think they're in the process of
reestablishing some some way to allow
the individuals to to protect themselves
what about drug screening while they're
on this they do so they do urine screens
while you're on pre-trial Services um
they offer drug counseling um electronic
monitoring right we can do electronic
monitoring which can include a GPS
bracelet so that you can sort of
geofence people to say you can't go to
certain locations and there would be an
alarm if they went within a certain
distance of a
location
um there's also a requirement that
you're employed or in school during
pre-trial
services so the the court
the courts certainly have that
available I
think for me one of the difficulties
with with some of the pre-trial programs
is
that the idea behind it is that we're
going to take people who would otherwise
be
incarcerated and put them on pre-trial
services and allow them in the
community but the reality is that what
ends up happening is you have people
that would otherwise be out on personal
recognizance bail unsupervised are the
ones that at least in my opinion make up
the majority of pre-trial
Services um and I think those are the
people that really could could benefit
from pre-trial Services I you know
certainly there's I I I'm sure someone
behind me will mention that and probably
knows far more about this than I do but
there was some program in New York City
where they simply texted people the day
before their court date and their
failures to appear drop drastically and
I think that one of the benefits of
pre-trial Services is you have someone
there to remind you of your court date
and to say we want to make sure you're
going to court tomorrow and you know and
you know exactly where they are if they
we anle bracelet yeah you also mentioned
Services generally um I know that over
the last year or so in Mar County um the
Human Services folks have R redesigned
their their structure uh and they have
now a um it's called a county Navigator
Pro program which takes referrals
they'll take referrals from law
enforcement self referrals uh public
defender defense councils you don't have
to be law enforcement involved to get a
referral to them and they'll help
navigate the the services within marrat
County help people establish
appointments um seek housing food
assistance medical assistance items such
as that it's working very very well they
also do uh drug assistance um you
remember when the opioid money started
coming from the opioid lawsuits started
coming some of that was earmarked to to
my office um but because of the
requirements within a statute I didn't
have a program I could plug that money
into um I worked with with the Human
Services folks moved that money from my
budget to theirs along with addition
they received I understand additional
opioid money and that helps fund some of
the uh um the medical treatment and the
drugs treatment um sub abuse treatment
and mental health treatment that's
available through your Navigator program
or at least the referral process and uh
uh uh and back filling costs so it
sounds like Marat county has some really
Innovative good things going on the
problem is that we write statutes that
cover the whole state so if the other
counties don't have it it's an unfunded
mandate and it's a problem right and at
this point the pre-trial Services
Program is a county by count right
program right but ours is pretty robust
a matter of fact I think they just
recently won uh the Navigator program
and Human Service just recently won an
award um national award uh for their uh
for their for their programming so it's
pretty robust it's pretty robust at this
point I'd like to open it up to members
of the committee to ask questions anyone
have any since I've been hogging all the
time can I make one more comment oh
absolutely by by all means um going back
a little bit you had talked about um we
had talked about the baale statute
pretty much the way it's written is
workable there needs to be some some
tweaks to it I know some of the
considerations that you mentioned were
getting the people who are uh multiple
failures to appear in front of a in
front of a judge rather than in front of
a bail commissioner um remember bail
Commissioners are a
statutory um their duties are outlined
by Statute uh there is a way to that you
may want to consider of um with certain
parameters bail Commissioners unable to
set bail it goes in front of a Judicial
officer the next day under the bail
commissioner statute uh limit their
authority to set bail rather than than
change the bail statute as it is say
under these circumstances an individual
who's on release from Department of
Corrections uh or on bail for two or
more a ausm or felonies uh and
rearrested must go uh they cannot set
bail or someone who has committed one of
these crimes is charged with one of
these crimes the bail commissioner
cannot set bail that triggers it going
before bail a Judicial officer the very
next morning and that leaves the bail
statute as it is and just limits the
bail commissioners and just directs
those in most in need of attention where
they should be Judes Could you um would
you mind emailing that to the committee
that suggestion I will I will with the
statuto notation I will um questions uh
representative um I just had a quick
question um you part of my past
experience involves um uh helping large
organizations convert paper based
processes to electronic processes and
one of the things that can gum up the
works like nothing else are some
important processes continuing to be on
paper while other important processes uh
continue to be
electronic one of the things that I'm
really curious about in this situation
after having listened to you go through
uh some of the delays and in processing
I mean to to what extent are are we
talking
about the court system
operating in the
1990s while the rest of us are operating
2020s maybe I I I yes I I don't want to
give I don't want to give the impression
it's all a paperwork electronic work sna
Fu um certainly some of it is is is or
may be Staffing I don't know the
Staffing I don't talk to the AOC about
their about their Staffing but when uh
my understanding from the super from
talking with some of the folks that deal
with the Superior Court more directly
nighted meeting the attorneys who file
things they prioritize what they're
accepting in their electronic filing I
think that that my outside view looking
in that
prioritization is is warranted but the
ability to get through those priorities
is staff-driven
and U that 20 that 30 days to accept a
request for a motion roke bail is
probably staff driven because they had
all these other priorities to get
through and right right all those other
priorities to get through so they
couldn't get to that individual priority
and attorney Anderson and I were talking
before we came in I'll let him elaborate
on on on this a little bit more um there
seems the state seems to have developed
their
electronic databases and systems
independent of one another to the point
where there are several and I don't know
if they're all talking to one another um
I know
right so right now in Circuit Court
everything is
paper so misdemeanor
violations all that is is paper and it's
the same system now that it was 20 30 40
years ago so the bail commissioner fills
out a
form and gives you your court date on
like here's your paper form court date
and then the bail commissioner has to
then
get themselves to the court to give the
other copy of that paper to the court so
the court knows this is when it's
on um it's I believe it's still a a
three-piece you know pink yellow white
form where the yellow copy goes to the
police the pink copy goes to the
defendant the white copy goes to the
court um in Superior Court they've got
electronic filing
that I don't believe the bail paperwork
is being electronically filed I think
that's
still yeah probably varies based on
where you are um and then the Supreme
Court has an electronic filing system
that's different than the superior
Court's electronic filing system so you
need a separate login to get to the
Supreme Court rather than Superior Court
there was an initi itive at one point in
Circuit
Court called J1 that I'm not fully
familiar with um but J1 was going to be
an electronic filing system and I know
that we've got a couple departments in
Marram County that use J1 and
electronically file and it's been my
experience that depending what court it
goes to there's different rules for J1
or different preferences for J1 and what
surprised me is at least one of the
courts we using you electronically file
through J1 but then you have to print a
copy of your electronic filing and
actually hand it to them because they're
still using you know everything in file
folders and if it's not in a file folder
it doesn't exist in in their world
so I know that the probate court right
now which is a division of the the
circuit court is was looking at doing
electronic filing and is I think has
sort of a pilot
project um but at this point traditional
you know misdemeanor violation criminal
court and in the future with the
elimination of felonies first felonies
as well in in Circuit Court are going to
be filed the same way now that they were
in 1982 on a on a written complaint and
to follow up on the on the felonies
going back we had a discussion with some
of the folks from the administrative
office of the courts recently uh and
several prosecutors and the question was
raised are the circuit courts going to
allow electronic filing and I I I think
I always wanted to ask the question
because marrat County um attorney's
office we cover five circuit courts in
three different counties propos the way
the judicial districts are are laid out
um and we go all the way over to to
Newport um and to
Hillsboro for our courts so um it's
conceivable that we have to have an
attorney traveling long distances to get
to something that may be in an an early
am hearing uh which we we'll get the
person there but when I ask hey can
things be filed
electronically the generic answer I got
well that's up to the local clerk yes
this comes down to a continuity issue
that uh why can't something why can't
the C fors get something to
electronically file and um I don't know
the answer that well I guess I down of
dollars but and even but even absent
dollars uh if there was a way to get it
to them even as a PDF attachment to an
email and then hard copy to follow when
the attorney gets there that allows them
to start the process docet things in get
things moving the only attorney gets
there they they give him the hard copy
but I don't think there's any yeah
standard and
that's I mean during coid a lot of the
courts had an email that you could you
could file through that email right and
when coid wound down some of those
courts told us stop using those emails
and some courts were more receptive to
continuing to receive pleadings by email
but go going forward back to your
question talking about electronic
systems
um the the caution that I would have as
an outsider looking into the into the
system is uh be wary of developing new
single systems rather than integrating
all of the
systems I think the former is uh we just
keep you uh in confusion the lat the
courts in confusion the latter will
integrate all our Courts for example a
bail Commission in Coos County who's
going to um a small Police Department in
Coos County should be able to to see the
prior nights bail form that was issued
in
Manchester like that but they can one of
the problems that we've discovered is
that you can be arrested in Manchester
one night and three days later get
picked up in Portsmouth and they don't
know you're on bail right they just so
in their in the in the bail
commissioner's eyes it's first offense
and you're unless they we heard Tales of
police officers finding bail slips
crumpled up on the floor of the car
that's how they found out they were on
bail yeah so it it's it seems this
technology issue at least in the
instance of bail regardless of the rest
of it needs to be fixed ASAP because to
blame bail Commissioners for people
being released multiple times when they
don't know yeah right right or police
not knowing the conditions of bail set
in another County so that they can
enforce those conditions and pick
someone up seems to be a a definite
Public Safety um lapse at this point and
especially as would relate for pending
DV work yeah exactly but as my
understanding DB orders are
right yeah
follow well absolutely
so I I think what we've been hearing is
that the the current processes that are
used in the court system in New
Hampshire um they're not
consistent so not only can processes
differ between the circuit court and the
superior court but they can even vary
within individual cour houses M yes um
to a large extent um it sounds SS like a
lot of uh process gets moved by people
in
shoes um and one of my one of my
questions is
um just because the process isn't
electronic doesn't necessarily mean it's
not reliable right um and so
um but what it sounds like is
because so much in the Jud Judicial
System um happens with paper and paper
transfers between people what it does is
it
creates what I think what you folks were
calling calling these gaps where you
have one group of people that has the
whole story or at least a pretty good
chunk of the story um and then a whole
other group of people who could really
use that information who basically have
no access to that information until
somehow that P piece of paper migrates
its way to the right person and
sometimes even after that it can take
weeks or months for anything to happen
with it depending on where it gets
prioritized in the court system is that
that a fair
summary General generic Su I think so
yeah no I okay I think that's true
and I've certainly found myself in the
position of preparing for bail hearings
and if I have more time preparing for a
bail hearing I've certainly done I've
called other jurisdictions to say hey do
you know this guy do you know what's
going on and I'm always amazed at the
amount of information I get when I
actually have the time to do that or get
someone on the phone who knows what's
going on because it gives you a much
Fuller picture of of what's going on in
in your case and you know know and the
information can work both both ways if
I'm doing a bail hearing and I have an
individual who has seven different open
cases and I see that on his criminal
record um if I know he's appeared for
every court hearing that he's appeared
that that was scheduled that's a good
thing you know and it changes the the
calculus that I may have on what I'm
going to request for bail they they may
be minor offenses all of them may be
minor offenses um uh he's uh he's not
committing serious against the person
offenses there maybe minor property
offenses but he's appearing at every at
every hearing he's going to that's going
to have a different uh Cal calculus in
my in my bail recommendation as would
the the opposite he has more serious
crimes that I don't know about because
they haven't made it to the to the uh
criminal record yet uh they were only a
day or so prior I don't have the bail
information uh and knowing that would
change the characters and in the Bale
statute itself it says I think says that
the uh person reviewing bail uses all
relevant information and um certainly
all of that information is certainly
you if the committee's done may I say a
couple of
things thank you uh most of what I want
to say it's already been said but I'm
determined to say it anyway so the um I
am a big fan of education and
consistency because prosecutor Steve
just said opened with 35 days the sign
in the Manchester bail off bail
compartment broom cubicle says 45 days
okay U the other thing is we're if
there's a no show we're all fans of due
process you want to hear I mean we just
we want to start slamming in those show
I had a guy
turned himself in who said yes I didn't
appear for court because I was in the
Essex Massachusetts County House of
Correction well the guy turned himself
in yeah I he was a good bet for PR the
last thing U people some of defendants
have a curious way of bragging I always
show up for my court dates that's
something to be proud of you always show
up for your court
dates by the way NCR fors they're
gone we've moved up to Xerox machines
now we're really moving along um the uh
I have many many times seen
nonappearance for court uh electronic
benchs they're invariably I've never
seen a hold maybe that's because the
police don't show them to me but it's
either a cash bail or
PR and I've not ever seen again it's
that's my experience I don't know what's
going on but look I the the real residue
that I want to leave is training and
consistency that's the big thing in my
book thank you for
listening we did hear that um and I
think it again it goes back to counties
whether or not the judges in those
particular cour houses say no bail or
they leave them as PR or some nominal
cash amount um but the we do as a
committee I believe have heard and we
observed because we went on a field trip
the green of the year to conquer
District Court and saw the list be
called off of people who were not there
default default default um so we
understand that that is a problem right
um it backs up the system it causes log
jams in the system and um it's
definitely something we need to look at
and training training is a huge thing I
know that there's all there's always
Nuance in in statutes and every once in
a while um I think the lack of training
shows its head when there's a
possibility of a life sentence in a in a
um in a charge and a person's released
on PR bail when the statute says that
they should be detained that happens
every once in a while and I I think that
circles around to the training and
experience level that we've talked about
I would have hoped in that case the
police would have jumped up and down and
pointed the statue um representative
Murray has a question certainly I'm just
trying to pull out like you know because
we've talked about a variety of
different problems in the system so like
what are you know the big pieces
and um you know we don't have access to
this data I don't know if you do but are
you seeing the issues being like
erroneously given PR bail like being a
huge cause of the issues here or is it
like non appearance like what are the
like the big glaring issues with the
bail system I guess right now in terms
of like is the pr bail being given too
often you know when you're talking about
bail Commissioners like maybe we just
don't let them rule on certain cases
like what is what is your what are your
thoughts on that I guess that's a tough
question to answer because there too
many moving Parts in each and every bail
decision um I think as a matter of
public policy though the there needs to
be some line drawn that establishes the
public policy where someone is
committing enough crimes there there
there's a default maybe a rebuttable
presumption that there are a danger to
the community and need to go in front of
a judge versus a bail commissioner or
that a crime that they commit um that's
charged is so egregious that you cannot
see a bail commission you must see a a
judge the next morning um and clearly
those are public policy uh choices um I
can tell you that that it seems to me
over the last three to four years that
um that
defendants uh no longer respect the cour
they no longer they no longer respect
the court orders uh and I think that
comes uh from a perception of nothing's
going to be done I'm not going to be
held why should I not appear or why
should I appear I think that circles
back with what I mentioned about the
multiple non- appearances and multiple
new crimes that are being committed uh
and certainly certainly is a small
population that uh that is repeat
offenders we're not talking about the
majority of
people yeah I believe the current
statute has a trigger if it's three
times or five times within certain
number of years and I think we maybe
need to look at lowering the thresholds
on those but it does contain them
currently in the statute I believe but
that just creates a presumption that
you're a risk of flight and then the
statute says you can't set cash bail
that the person can't make yeah so it's
kind of it defeats its own purpose of
the that's the difficulty is you have
someone who comes in and says yeah I
failed to appear four times and don't
have a dollar to my
name yeah that can be interpreted to
mean they can only be given
PR I have like kind of a two-part I
guess so is it fair to say the majority
of the pr bails are not the problem it's
just like a select group within this
like the majority are fine yeah I mean I
think the majority of people get PR bail
and and probably deserve and should
right um the concern is that some people
get PR bail
and continue to commit crimes which is a
concern and then you have people that
get PR bail and and don't come to court
and I think that the don't come to court
group can sort of be further broken down
into there are people who are
purposely you know dodging court and
then there's a group of people who just
couldn't get to an appointment if their
life depended on it because that's not
within their ability level yeah and
trying to figure
out where everybody fits in that and
what the appropriate remedy is because
it's obviously a different remedy for
everybody it's not a one-sized fits-all
solution yeah I think hearing about the
pre-trial Services you guys offer and um
also what you mentioned New York doing
with the notification like that feels
like both things that we should you know
Explore More and expand on because it
just feels hard to like take you know
when you have houseless people that get
arrested for trespassing for sleeping in
a public park you know over and over
like what other option do they have
available to them like can we really
just hold them indefinitely I I always
think back I had a case years and years
ago where I had a young woman who was
arrested charged she didn't come to
court but she worked at one of the
convenience stores in town and she
worked the overnight shift and all the
police knew like she was there from
Midnight night to 88: a.m. every single
night never missed a day at work but
like never came to her court dates and
it's not that
she's necessarily you know on the lamb
or fleeing law it's just that she didn't
want to deal with court she didn't go to
court
um but it's not like we didn't know
where she was you know interestingly the
police would go and say to her you have
a warrant you're under arrest and she's
like I can't leave I'm the only one one
here they're like turn yourself in
tomorrow morning at 8:
a.m. so and the local police in my
experience at least in marrat County are
pretty good about about approaching
folks that are not appearances and and
in a in in an appropriate manner based
on the circumstances that's my
experience and I believe that may
trigger some liability for the police
officers that once they go up to them
and say I know you have a warrant but
I'm not going to take you
he kills somebody later on you're you're
in it yeah I
mean I don't think there was any concern
that she was going to kill anybody no
not in that case but yeah no absolutely
yeah especially where you have issues
with mental health um yeah you just
never know and that's why I was curious
as to what services were available
because it seems to me circling back to
the beginning of this
um I didn't hear a lot about you know
the the the violence being let out I
hear more about the repeat def
defaults nuisance crimes and what do we
do with them mean that's a public policy
question not necessarily going to be
answered by bail because bail deals with
flight and and safety so we need to
figure out how to Loop those together so
that when someone does become Justice
involved they also become service
involved and I think that will cut down
on the former any U representative go
ahead thank you Mr chairman um so I just
wanted to get clarity on something and
then I also have a followup uh you said
everything in circuit court is done by
paper so does that mean that and
everything uh in Superior Court has
electronic filing and also Supreme Court
but does that mean that throughout the
whole court system for Superior Supreme
and circuit that all the bail or the
notifications for court dates are given
with paper does is there any electronic
uh uh notification of a of a court date
given to people so
in Circuit Court the the hearing notice
is I and this is again my experience and
belief and I can be I could be wrong
about this but in ciruit court it's
mailed to you so if it's mailed to your
last known address um and if you have an
attorney obviously it's mailed to the
attorney in Superior Court those
notifications are sent electronically
again in Superior Court we're usually
dealing with felony level offenses so it
would be emailed to the
attorneys um and not necessarily
directly to the
defendant and I know for many years in
conquer in the six Circuit Court
conquered uh in the criminal arraignment
sessions they would give the individual
a paper copy right in the courtroom when
they entered their ple of not guilty
they would issue them their paper copy
right in the right in the court
just because we generally didn't have
good addresses or it was hard to follow
up yes um and then my second question
is overall for the baale system
including people not showing up the no
shows how much is this a problem of a
decay in society where people cost of
living is going up more homeless
individuals more crime as a result
people just not like you said their
life's a mess uh they can't they just
can't they have no respect for
institutions anymore how much of it how
much of the problem is that and not
necessarily a structural statuto uh
issue that'd be hard for to say there's
cause and effect because I've just not
I've just not looked at it to be honest
with you yeah I I know
anecdotally there's a there's a
perception among some of the police
departments that in a larger
jurisdictions that some of the uh some
of the increased thefts are due to uh
due to drug issues um thefts selling
drugs to buy there's a there's a
anecdotal about that but I don't know if
there's any if there's any direct
connection but on a on
a just a how society's running basis I
I'd be hard foress to give you an answer
on that yeah and I think that's hard to
to quantify I think you know we can all
say that there are things that you know
people might have do or say today that
would have been Unthinkable to do or say
20 years ago
um so I I don't know I certainly think
that there is
a a
societal level of respect for the court
system that may be
declining how much of that is
self-inflicted is is really yeah I I
mean I don't and just so happens that
the that the decline in that respect is
with the same group
that the one right right it's a and to
be to be quite honest about it it's a
very small part of the population having
a very large impact on society which is
why we want to figure out how to address
these these small these small offenses
that are cumulative and they're like a
constant dripping on society and
draining resources and their their um I
believe the cities of Manchester and
nashille are suffering you know more
than most and that's why we see people
coming forward bringing these bills who
you traditionally wouldn't saying we we
need help something's happening and I
don't necessarily agree that it's the
idea of personal cognizance that's
causing it I I I firmly believe that
cash for the most part is a u is an
Antiquated Old English system of law um
that really doesn't apply as much
nowadays unless you already are somebody
means where losing that money would hurt
you if you don't have it in the first
place the design is to make you show
back up for core to get your money back
if you have no money setting bail on
someone that they can't afford really is
just saying I'm holding it so let's just
say we're holding it so I I think we
have to figure out the that line there I
can I can tell you I that that I
appreciate what your committee is doing
take a big picture approach to it rather
than uh uh than a PEC meal approach I
think that's important I think it's very
important we may have bitten off more
than we can
chew I think it's at the point now where
I'm going to ask the the governor um if
he might not in in in Persona the pope
and we call a criminal justice Summit or
Council of something because it seems
like every agency or piece of the
Criminal Justice System we talk to says
it's broken but they pointed a different
part and I think everybody needs to get
together and it's not going to be fixed
what I think has happened the system has
developed in an in an ad hoc way and I
think it's coming to a point where where
now the state needs to focus how
everything is going to make it a
consistent way throughout the entire
State um with your permission I'll ask
our Human Services folks to send you
information about the uh programs that
they um have within maram County um you
seem to the Committee Member seem to uh
have an interest in it I'll send you the
information on the bail commissioner
issue uh and uh if it's all right with
you chairman I have a copy of a letter
that I sent to Senator Carson and and
her standing committee on the Judiciary
back on bail on bail back in February
this year I'll give that to individuals
and I have additional copies for the
members who aren't here and when you
speak to the person about the pre-trial
Services thing if they could just give
us rough numbers of what what the cost
is for your county so we could maybe
possibly begin to extrapolate out on a
state level what that type of system
she's very proud of that program she's
worked extremely hard putting it
together over the last two years it's
working it's working very very well
sounds like she should be proud thank
you very much any further go ahead Just
One Last specific question that I had to
ask
um how much would and again you know
dollars dollars dollars of course but
putting that aside for a second how much
in your opinion would Transportation or
some means of transportation help with a
no-show uh problem making sure that
people who don't have a car or living on
the street could be driven to the court
in some way and again bringing up
the we have different populations and
you've got in terms of no- shows you
have people who are purposely ducking
the criminal justice system providing
them with Transportation isn't going to
get them there because they're going to
duck the transportation and then you
have a population that you know just
doesn't have the means to get there or
couldn't get there and I think that
would certainly certainly help a segment
of that population get there I believe
we already offered transportation that
comes with bracelets
I um and and like looking at I was
saying yesterday we had you know eight
failures to appear out of nine people I
can't tell you
if all eight of those people that failed
to appear are facing homelessness or
don't have cars or have other you know
massive life events that prevented them
from being there or what percentage of
those eight are fleeing Justice and not
coming to court but my guess would be
that more than 50% it's a resource issue
that if they were provided a ride or
maybe even a reminder they might show up
and that's that's a that's a tough
question because in New Hampshire you
have very rural areas um but along those
same lines I know that the
Human Services folks as part of their
projects has been working to expand um
available uh Transportation Systems
throughout the entire County I I think
they're working on even up uh into the
northern part of the county coming down
at the conquer so I'll make sure when I
ask them to send information to the
committee that that that they include uh
include what they're trying to do for
for transportation because the
transportation is also key in in the
Human Services side of things to get the
mental health uh service to get the drug
treatment services to get the uh the
medical services that that that people
need so I think it's all it's all
interrelated curiously the the text idea
how it lowered the appearances I believe
now that there Federal programs work
anyone can have a cell phone I I'd be
curious to know how many even of the
unhoused people have cell phones because
you can get it I think yeah the vast
majority of people we interact with have
cell phones so a text reminder you know
the night before and the morning of
saying to your court and and then maybe
one more that says you're now in warrant
could generate even if it cuts a
percentage um of the no- shows they
would save thank you for that any
further questions have a comment
actually y um The Rock Rockefeller
Center at Dartmouth um did a study and
it came out that um one the main issue
was Child Care responsibility yeah and
then Transportation then Employment and
then
forgot and intentional skips was the
last so it seems like um we do have a
problem and the text alerts might help
um their study showed that it does
definitely does
help yeah no that that doesn't surprise
me not at all thank you thank you and uh
we would appreciate any further
information as you said Thank you thank
you at this point we're going to take a
10-minute bi break and then come back
and at that point I think I'd like to
Chiefs
e
and we are back on the record um at this
point I believe there's one more County
testify if you could just tell us who
you are and where you are from and I
won't repeat everything we started with
heard thank you I'm I'm here for two
reasons maybe just to make a couple
comments
and to be available uh for your
questions and I'm I'm happy to begin
with one or the other depending on what
the
chair
um first of all I I hearkened back to
the last time we were here on bail
reform in
2018 and there was a tremendous dialogue
in
2018 regarding what the standard should
be
in New Hampshire and the argument was
essentially that there was a clear and
convincing evidence standard that was
mandated by
fergal um I I don't know it how clear it
has become since then but the Supreme
Court has said that that is not the
standard that we're required to use um
and that's in zuhowski the case that we
just recently
had
referenced and that was that was part of
the argument as to what standard we
should use in
evaluating um detention
I and the the the the zuhowski case said
in fergal we rejected the argument that
solaro sent a minimum standard for all
bail
inquiries and then it goes on to say
that the clear and convincing evidence
standard is not required
constitutionally in New Hampshire and
was that the um the majority opinion
you're reading from um yes I I would NE
I would never R you a minority opinion
um and in fact that was information that
I I cited to the court recently in in a
bail argument that we had over
a challenge to the
constitutionality of one of the
provisions of the baale statute not of
the bail statute itself but of the bail
law that allows for mandatory detention
on life
sentences so um I'm very
confident that we are no longer required
to use that
standard
um second thing I would like to say is I
think the first question we have to ask
when we're sitting here discussing bail
is what are we as a society willing to
tolerate and and what I mean by that is
we've had a lot of
conversations about crimes committed out
on bail we've had a lot of conversations
about failures to
appear both of those things are huge
problems and both of those things are
are something that I think we should ask
the question how much of this and under
what circumstances are we willing to
tolerate it in other words is there ever
an end to how many times you can not
appear before there's going to be a
presumption of
detention under what
circumstances are we going to say that
crimes committed out on bail have risen
to the level that we are no longer going
to allow that person to be accessing
bail and I think those are fundamental
questions that we have to ask as a
society and I think if we don't ask them
we end
up talking tremendous amount about the
why the why is important but at some
juncture it cannot be
dispositive in other words
we have Society has an obligation not
only to look at the offender and the
impact that the criminal justice systems
interaction with the offender has on him
or her but Society also has an
obligation to ask what is the impact on
Society on allowing this Behavior to
continue unchecked and be unwilling to
check
it and I think that in many respects the
frustration that we hear about bail
reform is is about an
unwillingness for society as evidence by
the bail statute and perhaps more
pointedly by its
application that we are unwilling to
protect society as a whole so I think
that's a fundamental question that we
have to
ask and then I think it's important that
I just convey a little bit about where I
come come from on Bale I have no
interest in cash B
ever I think people we should be making
an in or out determination and if we
make an out determination early on in
the process and nothing changes that's
perfect but if there is if we struggle
mightily as a society to bring that
person before the court or if we
struggle mightily as a society to with
that individual committing new crimes we
have to
reassess the situation and make a deter
ation that we are no longer willing to
accept this level either in volume or in
seriousness criminal conduct in volume
or seriousness of failure to appear and
all failure to appears are not created
equal for example if you failure to
appear the day of your
trial that's a biggie and but there's
got to be an there's got to be a
conversation at the legislative level
about what those lines are what are we
willing as a society to
tolerate and I don't think that question
um and just another quick observation is
I've heard numerous times last time I
was here um in 2018 and I've heard the
question again what about data
one of the things that we could do to to
generate data is to have the bail form
that we use in
court track the decision-making process
that's in the bail
statute
and that could be managed by the
administrative office of the courts and
maybe there could be a computer computer
program and we could figure out how many
Nosh shows how how many crimes committed
out on bail we don't have that data we
don't have the time or the energy to do
the data entry in our office it's a
small office but that data would be
valuable to you it would be valuable to
any decision making decision maker in
this Arena and I think having that bail
form track the statute decision making
process would be very helpful I don't
know how many of you have looked at the
current bail form that we use it's
really about a page in a fraction and
then a big space for the judge to sign
and it doesn't really track the
decisionmaking
process
and I think that that would be helpful
to everybody involved if we knew from
looking at the bail form that somebody
was charged with an offense while out on
bail if we knew that there were fire
prior failures to appear and that those
initial presumptions had been triggered
what we have is we have a one bucket
line item that says
essentially we we've decided that you're
released into the community having
evaluated this under the clear and
convincing evidence standard okay so
that's where I'm coming from
fundamentally is I think the biggest
thing that we need to do is decide what
we will not
tolerate and I'm happy to answer any
other
questions thank you in your
in in the courts that you practice
in the you heard the question I asked
initially of the other County attorneys
with regard to what are the types of
crimes that are really triggering this
this problem of these repeat out on
baales and are you of the same opinion
that it's these these nuisance level
crimes these misdemeanors such as uh
trespass um shoplifting these type of
things that are occurring on the repeat
while you're on bail no I I think think
I I are you let me just make sure I
understand the question is the question
is what is the crime being committed out
on Bale yeah what what types of crimes
because we have a list of 13 crimes the
Senate proposed and they're all very
serious crimes with violence against the
person but what we've heard anecdotally
is that's not what the people are being
picked up on time and time again while
they're out on bail it's lower level
misdemeanor crime some of which don't
even carry a jail sentence where they
found
guilty first so I think I think that
that's an
oversimplification um we see a broad
range of criminal Behavior I think
there's a difference between a uh a
misdemeanor shoplifting First Defense
you know committed on release and
somebody who commits a violation of a
protective order it's a misdemeanor I
think we have to be able to rationally
distinguish between those two things and
I wouldn't suggest that you know one one
new crime committed out on release
should automatically result in detention
but I think we should be able to
quantify those crimes or identify those
crimes that we certainly should make
that leap in other words if you're out
on bail and you commit one of these
crimes there will be a strong
presumption or mandatory detention
pending trial I I think that that's what
Society has to be able to expect a
criminal justice system that will act to
protect the interest of the
accused the the victim and the defendant
and right now um for whatever
reason you can have people out on
multiple layers of bail in multiple
cases over a year year and a half and we
never get to the point where we say
Society is unwilling to tolerate
this and and there I think the
legislature has it within its capacity
to identify those things that we will
not tolerate and what volume of those
things that are tolerable at a
relatively low level are not tolerable
at a at a high level and again um go
back to it I don't believe in cash bail
I I believe that file the rules out in
the community you're
good you're good to go if you're
dangerous if you're committing new
crimes that's a different animal if
you're not showing up that's a different
animal and I think we should focus on
those things and I also think we should
focus on whether or not we have the
right standard of review in the current
baale
statute with regard to that the clear
and convincing um was what was there are
you proposing um preponderance to the
evidence is is that the next level that
you would
prop I think that's a I think that's a
conversation that is worth
having um
because we've already
started
um historically probable cause
preponderance of the evidence 51 versus
49 is the standard by which we charge
people with criminal behavior and have
done so since the beginning of time in
New Hampshire
that's the standard that's in our
Constitution and we don't need a higher
more difficult standard to make bail
decisions um what we do need to do is to
decide when we want to exercise the
power of the state and identify those
things that are unacceptable to us as a
society and you have the you
collectively as the legislature have the
power to do that and I think that's what
we need to do bright line
in or
out and and and give the court the
discretion to make these decisions but I
thought that the last baale statute gave
something in other words the presumption
and took it
away when we created a standard of
review that was so difficult to achieve
and we failed to protect the community
okay go
ahead in listening to your testimony I I
guess I'm sort of struggling because we
have a list of RSA rsas here I just so
I'm clear what you're saying these are
ineffective what we already have that
you can hold a person um without they
out so well you I just need to be clear
about what you're inating what I'm what
I'm suggesting is that for virtually the
entire history of the state of New
Hampshire these decisions regarding bail
were were made at a preponderance of the
evidence standard okay and we are now
making them at a much higher standard
and that
logically um creates an additional
population that's in the community who
would otherwise have been detained at a
lower standard and it's interesting that
it's it's interesting that we create a
presumption in favor of
detention because these behaviors are
unacceptable to us and then we create a
higher standard by which we're going to
execute that direction that the
legislature has given us detain this
person and then we make it harder to do
that in the next step which is the
evidence if I'm unclear I
apologize no I just I think if I may her
her question was with regard to specific
crimes not the standard of review um we
have a list of 13 crimes proposed in the
Senate bill that would not be subject to
bail by a bail commissioner that would
have to be held by a judge um and I I
believe she was inquiring because of
your statements with regard to how much
will we tolerate which
crimes well I think I
think I think there's two two different
things okay the presumption is that a
that a judge is going to come up with a
a decision that is more likely to be
protective to the community I'm not sure
that that's necessarily the case the
judges are wetted to the law they do a
good job um you
know I think the question becomes we're
here
because Society is telling us that what
we're doing is not working that we are
not protecting the the citizens of our
community we're not protecting the
Integrity of the criminal justice system
as the system is currently operating and
if that's true we have to look at what
we can do
um it is unquestionably true that we can
have people out on bail multiples deep
multiple crimes on multiple new offenses
out on bail it is an epidemic you've
heard from my brother County attorneys
today um people don't show
up this is unacceptable behavior and we
have to qu we have to quantify what
we're willing to accept as a society and
say that there is a certain point a
certain level of behavior that we will
not accept or we're going to create a
greater likelihood that Society will
hold you pending trial and again I am
not one of these people who who believes
that um everybody should get
helped I think the presumption should be
a strong presumption that people remain
in the community but I think when you
start committing new crimes on bail that
we we really have to take a a good hard
look at what we're doing and make sure
we're being
effective and people showing
up you you can have you can
have hearings scheduled 10 hearings
scheduled and you're lucky if you get
two or
three uh on status
conferences and we issue bail orders we
bring them in and we start all over
again and we do it
again it is it is destructive to the
Integrity of the system it is
destructive to the Integrity of the
court and it's destructive to the
orderly process in giving Justice to
those who have been victimized and those
accused thank you for taking my question
again so again to better understand your
comments
um you have
rsas however what I hear you saying and
tell me if wrong that um the system is
not doing what they're supposed to those
that
actually supposed to enact the law are
not necessarily doing what they're
supposed to
do because if it's here and it says you
have the right to do this about that
person and it's not being done where is
that happening it's not happening in the
law because it's in the law no no the
the so the the
unless unless I'm mistaken I do not
believe you're referring to mandatory
detention I'm talking about all rather
you're mandatory or or rather whether
you're bailed or not bailed or those
things there are very few
circumstances in which there's going to
be mandatory detention other words the
the law does not give the court
discretion to release
someone okay the vast majority of
cases um are there the court has
discretion and the last time we were
here creating
legislation we created
presumptions in the law that said under
these circumstances there will be
presumptively detained some of that had
to do with conduct out on bail some of
that had to do with um the nature of the
offense a and then we basically said we
really weren't serious about it because
we elevated the standard of
review um unless the court finds by
clear and convincing evidence
that and it was the lord giveth the lord
taketh
away and the standard of
review is as much a consideration
as what you say you are prohibiting or
presumptively
prohibiting so if I just for
clarification you're saying that okay we
we said we will not tolerate as a
society a b and c they're presumptively
detained yes and however we're going to
make you prove it by such a high bar
that it's difficult to prove therefore
we really but at at the time though were
we not operating under the presumption
that the clearing convincing was or may
still be the standard or well it I think
that was what was the argued to the I
know that was was argued
and that was not the law
then that is not the law now it is
clearly not the law
now I think I think that people had a
good faith basis for making the argument
that fergo stood for that um I didn't
believe it okay um and um has the New
Hampshire Supreme Court um opined on it
to the best yes that's the Oh I thought
you were reading a US Supreme Court no
no no no that's the that's the New
Hampshire Supreme Court the New
Hampshire Supreme Court the zalinsky
zisy that's these motorcyclist the seven
people dead okay yeah that's the case
the New Hampshire Supreme Court said
that the clear and convincing standard
is not required they said it essentially
that it would be a misreading of fergo
to believe that's
true and um and I don't fault the people
who looked at
fergo uh and I'm not saying that the
people who argued that position were
dishonest I that's not the case there
was a legitimate robust debate I can
tell you and I believe that almost
anyone who practices law would tell you
that that question has been resolved
by Zukowski and with regard to the US
Supreme Court was that the Sano case no
that was or there hasn't been a US
Supreme Court I don't think there's any
US Supreme Court case that would alter
the discussions that we're having here
the argument regarding the burden of
proof which was one of the central
arguments that we had back in 18 um was
over how we interpret uh the New
Hampshire Constitution fergal was a New
Hampshire Constitution case it cited
solarno um which was
a court of appeals case I believe from
the West Coast it was an Arizona court
of appeals case to the federal court of
appeals and that
site created this conversation about the
standard of proof so that wouldn't even
apply to this District if it was from
well no but but but the argument was
that it did that that's what happened in
fergal mhm Supreme Court said no that's
not really what happened in
fergal and it's very clear uh in in
zuhowski okay we'll read that case thank
question I had a question um you seem to
be pretty firmly of the opinion uh that
cash bail shouldn't be part of the
system and I am aware of other states uh
where cash bail has has been eliminated
I guess my question is to you um I know
that some of those states have struggled
um in the same way New Hampshire uh has
has struggled um you know with things
like non-appearance and things like
that what are other states doing that
that don't have cash bail uh that seems
to be working you know um aside from
Just Simply Having a a fairly clear road
terms what I what I guess is what I'm
saying is first of all I'm not an expert
on on what other states okay have done
um my my my dislike for cash
bail is that it makes a decision as to
somebody's Liberty based on how much
money they have and that's really not
what we should be doing okay from my
perspective
um and if somebody is a good
risk and I think there should be by and
large a presumption that most people are
good risks that they should be released
on their word to appear and be
good and then Society responds to the
failure to appear and the failure to be
good and we ask
ourselves how much and what kind of
failure to be good will we
tolerate and how many failures to appear
will We Will We tolerate as a
society at what point do we say that you
are not meeting your end of that bargain
by being good and by showing up and I
think there should be at some juncture a
bright line where we say no longer no
longer can you we tolerate this you're
detained pending trial no longer can we
tolerate this you're detained pending
trial
and what I see in the exist the the
prior bail
Bill and how it is being applied as
currently written is an almost Limitless
Toleration for failing to appear and an
unacceptable often times toleration for
new Criminal
behavior and if I had to quantify or
rate the importance new crimes are
probably far more important than
failures to appear I don't know what the
number that the legislature would find
intolerable on failures to appear but I
think the number of times you can commit
new crimes while out unconditional
release should be relatively low and I
think there should be a gradiation
between serious Criminal offenses
felonies and assaults violations of
protective order even if they're
misdemeanors those kinds of things we
cannot tolerate as a society regularly
out on bail and maintain protection for
system thank
you see no further questions thank you
you
to good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is John bonsam the
chief in Bedford and currently the
president of the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police and I
thank you for the opportunity to provide
you with some information today that
perhaps you don't have that may be
Germain well not maybe but will be
Germain to your discussions and
deliberations with respect to uh B
reform and first I'd like to mention
that the previous um uh County attorney
Hathaway I I I can't uh Echo his
comments um and in full support of um
the the pre premise upon which he bases
his opinions and um his concerns uh
which are totally shared by the chiefs
of police but what I want to bring to
you today is information uh that is
particular to uh New Hampshire and it
goes to the questions and discussions
that you've heard um quite often about
um people that have been arrested and
released and arrested and released and
so while we haven't had a system by
which um the state or law enforcement
agencies can tulate uh those numbers
with any degree of accuracy I'm here to
tell you that state actually did enjoin
a contract with the Council of state
governments in
2022 and is called the New Hampshire
Justice reinvestment act an initiative
and essentially what that initiative did
was to under contract require the uh
National Council of state governments to
look at um the high utilization and
persistent utilization of County jails
uh throughout New Hampshire and to
determine um and to determine why this
was happening and perhaps uh develop
some key points and elements so very
briefly without keeping you long um I
think this information may be very
helpful to you and I'll provide uh the
committee with a copy uh of this as well
before I
leave essentially uh there were three
challenges that the state identified uh
one that there's a small number of
people cycling through the jails in New
Hampshire uh that are utilizing uh a
substantial number of resources at Great
cost to the counties and to the state uh
two High utilizers of jail Services had
more complex and more frequent
Behavioral Health and other related
encounters than non-high utilizers of
jail services and thirdly and this is
something that was discussed previously
today in your committee that re-entry
and Community Services vary greatly uh
from County to County uh in New
Hampshire contributing to long wait
times uh and significant gaps in um
reintegration Services particularly for
the high utilizers of Jael resources so
here are some essential key findings and
these are numbers that I think are are
both starking and
revealing um jail High utilizers
accounted for 9% of the jail population
but actually
34% of jail entrances and approximately
29% of jail cost for fiscal year 19 to
21 let me say that again 9% of the jail
population um accounted for 34% of the
jail entrances that means that a
relatively low number of people are
cycling through New Hampshire County
jails over and over and over again which
is consistent with with what you've
heard from members of uh law enforcement
myself uh as well as County prosecutors
um now of those 9% that account for 34%
of the jail entrances U remarkably and
sadly
84% of those uh 9% were diagnosed with a
substance use disorder as the primary
diagnosis now this information is coming
from Medicare data that was obtained by
the Council of state government so these
These are actually uh diagnoses uh that
were obtained as a result of medical
records so 84% of that 9% presented with
a substance use disorder and
69% of the
84% right 69% of the
84% um presented with opioid related um
primary diagnosis right and uh
interestingly enough only 33% presented
with alcohol rated primary diagnosis
right um if and Behavioral Health uh
constituted
73%
so uh overall uh 59 89% of the high
utilizers in fiscal years 15 to 21 had a
history of Medicaid enrollment uh and of
that population 93% had a behavioral
health claim so what we're seeing here
is uh factual data as as a result of
this study that is particular to just
new Hampshire now this is just New
Hampshire uh with respect to those folks
that are cycling through County jails
over and over again um that are
accounting for a high number of jail
entrances but actually are very less
than 10% of the population and of that
population a significant um amount of
those folks uh over 80% 84% actually uh
were diagnosed with an um opioid related
substance use disorder uh or a substance
use disorder and um 70% had an opioid
substance use disorder um diagnosis uh
the takeaway from the law enforcement
perspective uh and again I'll provide
the committee with a copy of this is
that this um
validates um the concerns that you've
heard uh from uh County attorney
Hathaway and myself and others in law
enforcement regard ing folks that are
cycling through the
system uh over and over again um and so
the other key elements uh that were
obtained as a result of this study in
comparison to the nonh high utilizers
the high utilizers in fiscal year 19 and
fisc through fiscal year 21 had a
greater likelihood of being booked into
jail for lower level crimes such as
criminal trespassing probation parole
violations and failure to appear
uh on bail charges um and were less
likely to be booked in for violent crime
so there there are two distinct issues
that um I think are presented uh for you
as a committee to look at one is the
concern of the um Community uh and
Society has on how people that are
charged with violent crime are handled
initially um through the baale system
and secondly this particular study looks
at um and validates the concern for
those folks uh who are committing
low-level crimes that are cycling
through the system over and over and
over again uh and then finally uh the
key takeaway is that and we know from
law enforcement that most of those folks
that are uh charged and um processed
through the system uh certainly at least
in in our County and Hillsboro County
the most populous County uh are um
committing those crimes and having an
underlying substance used to sorder
diagnosis right um but yet they're
continually released um bail orders
often times uh and most uh most
oftentimes require the individual who
has that underlying substance use
disorder that was brought to the
attention of the Court typically by
defense counsel um uh places that
individual on orders to seek treat
treatment and in the vast majority of
those cases those folks um don't seek
treatment um they reoffend uh fail to
appear uh they miss their court dates
and they cycle back through the system
again and again um so one uh one of the
areas that we've explored uh and some
counties are exploring it I know
Hillsboro County the superintendent of
jails is looking at a um incarcerating
program that would uh interrupt the
cycle of offending and release by folks
who have an underlying substance use
disorder by requiring them to be
committed to jail for a period of time
to undergo a uh medically assisted um
proven uh successful uh drug and
substance use treatment program before
they're released um that would interrupt
the cycle of 89% of that 9% um that are
cycling through the county jails um uh
over and over and over again so uh very
interesting numbers this is again
Germaine um to New Hampshire and I think
is important for you folks to hear and I
give thank you for the opportunity
giving it to you today Chief if you
could um for the benefit of the
committee those those were jail numbers
not prison numbers so could you talk
about what offenses are are sentenced to
jail versus prison um so we're talking
mostly those are mostly misdemeanors or
at least that they pled to or accepted
time for is that correct that's correct
right so so for the benefit of the
committee if you're sentenced for a
felony you go to state prison if it's a
misdemeanor or you plead to a
misdemeanor that used to be a felony you
end up in in the jail system so those
numbers applied mostly to the defenses
that we're discussing as far as um the
the burden on the
system and did you have anything else
you wanted to add based on what you've
heard here today no this is uh this is
all uh you know County attorney hat to
way did a remarkable remarkable job in
um uh putting the problem uh in
perspective uh before you as the
committee um to get a more strategic and
50,000 foot level uh uh to try to get
our arms around uh What uh is facing us
um that has led to the perception that
the criminal justice system is more of
an annoyance than it is a corrective
mechanism in syst Society is based on
the lack of respect of that system due
largely in part to uh the the fact and
it is fact that most people are are are
not uh incentivized to follow the law uh
because of a lack of
consequences right and so uh what we see
here is in these numbers a clear uh
remarkable U manifest station that uh a
number of people uh a small number of
people as County attorney Hathaway had
indicated are responsible for a high
number of reoffending type of crimes so
those are the folks that that we need to
focus on uh not the other uh
91% uh of folks but we need to focus on
that 9% that are accounting for 34% of
the jail entrances and and again these
are jail entrances not arrest so that
means that these folks likely have been
arrested released on PR Bond a number of
times before they actually land in a
county jail so uh that's another
consideration that I think needs to be
brought to light
here you discussed um
a a mandatory um substance abuse program
that would be um taken care of in in
while you were in car
erated that's post conviction I take it
that that wouldn't be while you were on
bail what services are available that
you're aware of that could be used while
someone was on bail for example
someone's arrested bailed picked up
again and it's determined that they have
a substance abuse problem versus saying
okay we're going to hold
them what what's available as an
alternative to actually interrupt that
cycle while they're on bail by sending
them somewhere for for some type of
services
as the study indicated those Services
vary greatly and widely by County um
some counties have a more robust
pre-trial Service uh and um oftentimes a
reintegration program and other counties
based on volume and staffing issues have
much less so one of the recommendations
certainly would be to have the state
look at um providing for a consistent a
well-funded um defined pre-trial service
system throughout all the counties to be
able to better serve folks the um the
introduction of opioid abatement funds U
which are now flowing into the state uh
every year um we believe could be used
uh to support the development and the um
deployment of medically assisted
substance use treatment programs in
county jails uh that I believe uh in my
years 27 years in Drug law enforcement
um and 45 years on law enforcement per
se uh suggests to me that folks that um
are under bail conditions because they
have a substance use disorder and
continually refuse to Avail themselves
of the treatment and Recovery systems
that are out there today much more so
than there were six or seven years ago
so those services do exist but they they
frankly ignore them um and they reoffend
a medically assisted incarcerated
treatment program would be uh available
hopefully funded through this opioid
abatement fund uh uh to be able to
interrupt that cycle and again uh as
attorney cath attorney hathway indicated
this is not for the very first time that
a person uh is arrested uh for a
low-level crime and has a substance use
disorder diagnosis uh this would be for
those folks that um are in the gap
between multiple offenses um and
releases and those that are then
eventually sentenced to drug court
because a lot the drug courts which do
work well unfortunately do not have the
capacity do not have the capacity to
deal with the tsunami of folks that as
these numbers indicate um are producing
in the state so something in
between um where we're simply releasing
folks with a substance use disorder and
they are not availing themselves of
treatment and then waiting one or two
years where they've accumulated um a
whole range of offenses and re and
releases and then perhaps maybe put them
in drug court let's stop that py
uh before it gets to the point where
it's gone well beyond what's as attorney
haway so aply put Society is willing to
tolerate thank you
questions represent
M I wanted to thank you for bringing
that report to light um and I also
wanted to let the other members of the
committee know that this was actually
the report that I sent out to everybody
uh about a month ago and we when we
started so
um I think this is one of the maybe the
single most nagging uh systemic issue uh
that we're dealing with uh currently um
and uh and unfortunately there doesn't
seem to be um uh any super reliable way
at this point of of dealing with it I
know that the when the commission made
its recommendations there were some
people who who looked at them I was I
was one of them um and I think a huge
question for us
is where we go from here um in the
context of trying to rework or rework
our bail laws I think it becomes easier
for us to do that if we know that
there's a way we can actually do what
you're suggesting we do which is to try
to find a way to to break this
cycle um so I am 100% in favor of of
anything that you know that can that can
do that um but one one question I did
have for you is in
terms so breaking the cycle seems to be
something that we can do uh it it seemed
to it seems to require a conviction to
do that um this doesn't seem we we can't
just we can't presume people are guilty
of an offense before they've been been
convicted in in a court of
law are there ways uh that you've heard
about in your conversations with other
Chiefs or national
organizations how other states other
localities may be finding a way to get
people some help uh before
conviction um
the and I I think you know one of the
things we've heard about our our various
pre-trial programs so one of the things
that I'm curious about is how are so
many people
falling you know kind of into those
cracks even though those programs exist
you know what what's what's happening
you know where are the where are the
holes that we need to close I guess
that's my
question thank you for your question and
uh I hope if I understood it properly
I'll I'll try to address I think there's
a couple of questions in there there one
um relates to how
to um address pre-conviction
those folks who have a underlying
substance use disorder um that is uh
driving their criminal Behavior to to a
large extent and we here in New
Hampshire uh if we for a
moment dial the clock back to 2014 and
20 5 when the opioid problem began to
surface um in a large way in in the
state of New Hampshire we were we were
not in a position in the state of New
Hampshire to be able to offer with any
degree of certainty or
regularity uh substance use treatment or
Recovery Services in fact I can recall
at a conference at the Bedford Village
in um there was a uh speaker and that
speaker was from Florida and in doing
some research I was able to determine
that there were more treatment in
recovery beds in the city of Tampa
Florida at the time than there was in
the entire State of New Hampshire right
but since then we've come a long way in
providing for services treatment and
Recovery in the state of New Hampshire
uh some may say that we're not where we
are yet or where we should be yet but we
have come quite a long
way the problem that you bring uh into
discussion is the individuals or segment
of that cohort that are facing criminal
charges with an underlying substance use
disorder uh and have been
told by the court that you need to treat
that um and yet they fail to Avail
themselves of the court-ordered
treatment that is required to address
their underlying
diagnosis uh that goes to the
psychology of of drug addiction and the
state of substance use here in the
United States and as some of the members
of the committee may know I spent 27
years with us Drug Enforcement
Administration uh and so I have quite a
bit of knowledge
about um that area of of
psychology and criminal element and I
can tell you that um the substance use
problem that we face today here in the
United States is worse than it's ever
been in the almost half century that
I've been involved in law enforcement
across the
country uh with more than 110,000 people
dead from drug
overdoses um most of those not all but
most of those folks from disadvantage
communities uh is um is a is a
stain um on the American
flag and we were still struggling to try
to deal with this um and yet haven't
found the
solution one thing I can tell you and I
think it's it comes from both my
experience ladies and gentlemen as well
as simple common sense that you all
possess and that simply is this today
the powerful nature and addictive nature
of the drugs and the morbidity
associated with the drugs that are
available on the streets of conquer New
Hampshire not far from where you're
sitting or in the streets of Manchester
or most communities in New Hampshire
are so powerfully
psychologically as well as
physiologically addictive that people
will risk their lives on a daily basis
multiple times knowing full well that
this could be the last time that they
take a drug or a breath of air on this
Earth and yet they still continue to be
engaged in that behavior there is no
amount of criminal incentive
that's going to stop
someone uh from engaging in that
behavior so what what what do we
do uh and I think these numbers that you
sent out to your
committee give us a glimpse of what we
may be able to do because there are
effective substance use treatment
programs out there today right there are
and we need desperately ladies and
gentlemen need to leverage the criminal
justice system to take people who are
continually engaged in this destructive
behavior that cost so many lives more
than 480 in the past couple of years per
year in New Hampshire and we're on the
trajectory to at least uh meet that this
year uh to take those folks and say we
know that this addictive nature of this
type of problem that you have is not
something that
is most people can bring themselves to
address themselves so what we are going
to do is we're going to use the criminal
justice system as a lever to say look
while we have you as a result of this
criminal charge and we know that you
have this problem here's a uh program
that is 67 to 73% effective in solving
the that problem that is causing you the
destructive
Behavior why don't we do that more often
the funds now we used to say that we
didn't have the money it's a it's
expensive uh when we first started to
have the opioid problem in New Hampshire
back in 145 and 16 I believe Rockingham
County was leading the charge with U
incarcerate of treatment programs and it
was a really good program but it's
costly now we have a a lot of money
coming in by truckloads into the state
of New Hampshire from the opioid
settlements why don't we use that money
right to interrupt the cycle of criminal
behavior and address at least an 80 80%
of that 9% the underlying substance use
disorder that's driving that criminal
Behavior if that's successful based on
the numbers that you see from these
medically assisted treatment programs
such as the one that's used in the main
State Prison
that the federal government is looking
at uh as an example right we would
reduce substantially reduced the number
of people that are offending tying up
criminal justice police courts um uh
pre-trial services and jail
resources and they would be productive
members of
society if we can just bring that number
down by half not even the 60 or 70%
it would be a remarkable Improvement in
where we're going but to be able to do
that this committee needs to look at
ways of allowing the criminal justice
system to be able to operate more
effectively as County attorney Hathaway
uh so aply stated by reducing the
tolerance of what Society is willing to
allow up to the point of limit Limitless
reoffending
which people will
do if they have an underlying substance
use disorder that drives them to the
up turn my mic back on um
so so it sounds like one of the things
that you would support would be
diversionary programs uh for people um
who have substance abuse issues uh who
were frequent offenders is that is that
correct that that's correct uh diversion
programs for those folks but it would be
court ordered mandated and for certain
people that continued to reoffend and
not Avail themselves of treatment so in
other words they have already presented
a history of being told
you've you've offended you have this
underlying substance use disorder you've
been ordered into treatment three four
times you have not fulfilled that
obligation so now the system criminal
justice system is going to say you are
incarcerator that's the key
element follow up
so in terms of of actually implementing
a system like that it it sounds like
that's something that if we adopted it
uh we might want any judge uh in New
Hampshire to be able to do um uh not
just a judge in a drug court correct
that would be any judge absolutely
Because by the time these defendants
reach drug court they have a massed
trajectory and history of of fending and
reoffending that is substantial much
more than you know what we see here in
these
numbers one more followup and and would
and by and by judge I think I mean are
we talking about just a judge so looking
at you know some of our conversations
around Bill Commissioners and folks like
this should should a bail commissioner
have the ability uh maybe this is
something that appears on a check off so
instead of a cash bail it could be
participation in a program like this or
would a bail commissioner even have
knowledge that a person is a frequent
offender the bail Commissioners don't
have the knowledge or the ability to be
able to make those kinds of decisions um
the the bail Commissioners uh uh that
make uh the right decisions uh across
the state
um are the ones that we don't hear about
and the cases that we don't hear about
um the bail Commissioners that make what
we considered to be um less than optimal
decisions with respect to releasing
folks that have committed allegedly
committed a violent crime uh are the
ones that um I think that we we talk
about and so what we're really looking
at here is designing a system
that provides a bit more um Direction a
bit less discretion bit less not a lot
less but a bit less discretion that
allows the courts and um the system to
be able to be more effective in dealing
with folks that um are presented in
basically two categories those that can
are alleged to have committed violent
crime and those those that uh are
reflected in these numbers the 9% that
account for
34% um which are those that continually
reoffend the vast majority of those with
a substance use
disorder Chief if I if I could um so I
don't think you'd find much disagreement
on this committee that that those things
are necessary um with regard to the
treatment offer amps but were it to be
law at this minute in a judge were to
say okay you are going to this mandatory
um
service are there such places do we have
this set up I mean how far out are we
looking before we could even Implement
such a system where these folks could go
some of these programs currently exist
in some counties uh I know that the
superintendent in Hillsboro County uh is
seeking to establish uh medically
assisted incarcerated treatment program
uh in Hillsboro County um and so I would
hope that there would be leadership um
at the state level uh within the courts
um uh and others to make sure that this
opioid abatement money uh or at least a
portion of it is being uh devoted to
standing up uh what appears to be very
effective treatment programs in in the
county jails that has to be in place the
judges will not sentence someone to a
program that doesn't exist and that's
been and that's frankly been one of the
problems right uh the judges do have
folks before them um but if there's no
incarcerated treatment program available
then often times those folks are
sentenced um to a term U of
incarceration all
suspended uh and then told to get
treatment outside the system which they
typically don't do
with regard to mental health again it
goes back to available beds I know we
just completed a facility but
disappointingly I think it ended up with
like a handful of beds um versus the
hundreds we would need are you aware of
anywhere um that are not government
ordered or run that these folks could be
sent to to get back on their meds and
treatment and things of that
nature that is probably one of the
largest gaps that we Face here in the
state New Hampshire and I don't think
New Hampshire is different than most
other states the mental health Gap in
terms of facilities um and the ability
to be able to
um treat as well as provide services to
folks who have um a mental health
diagnosis uh and to follow them through
um is is largely non-existent and I
think that again the study points out
the wide
um U
differentiation um Divergence between
the existence of pre-trial Services uh
throughout the state uh that mechanism
could uh provide some degree of a stop
Gap measure as I think you're indicating
here to help along with the system um
for those that um suffer with a mental
disorder
thank you for your testimony we appr
thank you so
much oh
representative I'm not on the
subcommittee but they're nice to me so
uh the I can't disagree of course with
the dialogue that you and representative
news had but one thing that has caught
my attention is can somebody be forced
into a program we can incarcerate them
but you what are you going to have just
because you're well-intentioned and it's
effective will they cooperate and just
some people won't what do you do can
they be my question is can they be
forced into a program even post
conviction well thank you for your
question and I I I I think that what we
see uh in the numbers is that when an
individual is
released uh under bail conditions um
some of which require the individual to
seek substance use disorder treatment we
find that uh significant in fact a
majority of those folks don't seek that
treatment um the system the the courts
can mandate them participate in much
like the system that is currently in the
mainstate prison a medically assisted
treatment program now again it's not
100% effective but it can force the
individual to be in the program whether
them thank thank you so
much I believe last but not least I'm
going to give um Professor Sher u 10
minutes of our time before we go as you
requested I had to put a limit on
you
it's a good limit because I have to be
at school at one
o'clock
um I agree with a lot of what's been
said
today
um with one exception um you I've known
County attorney hathway for over 40
years now sad commentary on both of our
ages um and he's wrong that there are
not there there are not mechanisms in
the current bail statute to deal with
people who fail to appear repeatedly to
deal with people who are violating bail
conditions they are there and uh I think
this committee is sophisticated enough
at this point and in uh looking at the
statute to know that they are there I
will pass out uh to the committee um uh
uh a copy of
5972 with three areas highlight
that deal with that
circumstance um because and I'll do it
I'll do it after I finish testifying
because it's there and so I don't think
the problem is the statute you know
you've heard this from me several times
the problem isn't the statute the
problem is implementation you know be it
educating judges be it educating bail
Commissioners that's the
problem uh part two I agreed medically
assisted treatment while incarcerated
can be effective but uh it's when people
are sentenced it it
is very
difficult well I'm put it a different
way the best way to deal with those with
possible substance abuse problems or
mental health problems is to use that
opioid money for pre-trial services in
every County because if you don't do
that you're leaving it to judges to
diagnose whether somebody has a mental
health issue diagnose whether they have
a substance abuse issue and they're not
good at that um and you know we don't
want that system so yeah I I think uh
potentially uh if we have a pre-trial
service system in every County where
professionals can do that diagnostic
Behavior Behavior then we start to have
uh a a a bail system that works remember
we're not talking about people who are
sentenced and and my belief is I haven't
read the report but my belief is the
numbers the chief t uh talk to us about
primarily covers people who have already
been sentenced that really aren't
talking about pre-trial people um and
you and those numbers are no surprise
whatsoever um you know but I think we're
not talking about pre-trial people the
repeat offenders that keep cycling
through the jail are cycling through the
jail on
sentences um so um I'm going to my list
um you've heard this again for me but
you
know bail Commissioners have by Statute
have all the authority that judges have
as to bail they
do um so so any sense that the bail
Commissioners really don't have the
power to do X Y or Z is not the
case
um I would uh I would suggest that
um police begin to consider uh given
their concern that they don't have
enough information about an individual
to make a good to really provide all the
necessary information to bail
Commissioners or even judges well for
those people who are not immediately
dangerous and they need to get off the
Street
instantly instead of arresting people as
soon as they can maybe take an extra day
to do gather bail facts to see to run a
prior record to see me how many failures
to appear this person has to find out
more about this purpose person for
making a bail argument rather than
arresting them as quick as they can um
and not having all the information that
would allow them to make an effective
argument to the bail commissioner or a
prosecutor to a judge you know no
question there's some crimes they have
to arrest them immediately for but I I
think that's a proposition worth
considering um you know I disagree uh
with the interpretation of the um uh
that attorney County attorney Hathaway
did of the uh clearing convincing
standard you know the fergal case uh
which was referred to in uh in that CA
in the case he mentioned whose name I I
not even going to try and pronounce that
begins with z um the fergal decision was
a pre uh the clar and convincing
standard didn't exist in New Hampshire
back uh other than in homicide cases
other uh except back in in 2010 when
feral was
decided um so um I point that out um I
think I'm almost done uh there is a lot
of data and the court has this data that
uh a texting system for reminding people
that they've got a court date coming up
has been shown to be very effective in
various uh circumstances I think there's
a great study out of Pittsburgh uh the
city of Pittsburgh if I'm not mistaken
uh the the the court system the district
court system several years ago uh set up
a pilot program in Rochester District
Court to do
that and then the the pmic head uh and
it it it didn't make any sense at that
point for all sorts of reasons so the
court had set up a a test of that
texting system uh and I think it's worth
know uh I think I'm almost done uh one
last
thing I think uh attorney Halon attorney
Enders correctly said when
asked the majority of people out on PR
Bale are not a problem I think let's
keep in
perspective the nature of the problem
we're dealing with the huge majority I
believe of people who are out on PR bail
are not a problem we're talking about a
small group and we're talking about a
small group for whom bail Commission and
judges have the authority under the
statute to deal with the
circumstance um and for whatever reason
you know we've had discussions in
various ways about this the baale
statute hasn't been used to do that just
one last example if you look
at
um uh where is it ah uh the bail statute
Roman numeral
3 uh when in the provision that talks
about ass assuring the court appearance
of charged
persons paragraph two says if the court
determines by preponderance of evidence
that a person has failed to appear on
any previous matter charged as a felony
Class A misdemeanor or DWI or reasonably
equivalent offense in an out of state
jurisdiction three or more times in the
past five years or twice on the present
case there shall be a rebuttable
presumption that re release will not
reasonably assure the appearance of the
person as required so two failures to
appear on a on the present case and the
Court's got all a lot of authority to
deal with that again an example
of we don't need to work the bail
statute over significantly because it's
already there there's some other Pro
systemic problem in be it education or
or whatever be an education of
prosecutors of judges of bail
Commissioners that's the issue um and
last I'll repeat pre-trial uh pre-trial
services in every County would make a
huge
out
almost got sorry about that um in the
current statute um one of the things
that it does say is and you took us
through part of this if the court
determines by a preponderance of the
evidence that a person has failed to
appear on any previous matter charged as
a felony Class A misdemeanor DWI or
reasonably equivalent offense in an
outof State jurisdiction then it lays
out um you know three or more times
within the past 5 years years or twice
on the present case there should be a
rebuttable assumption that the release
will not reasonably assure the
appearance of the person is required So
currently we're talking about felonies
Class A misdemeanors driving while
impaired other offenses a lot of the
offenses that we're talking about though
you know by the people who have regular
encounters with the court system would
not fall into that category uh I think
the ones we worry most about W uh you
know there are
violations uh that and Class B
misdemeanor that account for some of
those the problem there is uh of a
different order a different policy
question neither violations nor Class B
misdemeanors even if you're convicted
you're not going to get a jail sentence
right so to hold somebody pre-trial on a
charge for which assuming they have
multiple failures to appear that they're
not going to get a jail sentence with
that's a that's
a difficult thing uh arguably should
never be happening um but uh you know
that that that raises a question though
is is contempt of court jailable yes so
failure to appear theoretically could be
charged as contempt of court it it could
be charged with contempt of court uh and
I I don't you know one needs to judgment
needs to be used as to whether if
someone is committing repeat violations
like littering we ever want to you know
uh put them in jail for any period of
time
whatsoever
who
is Paul how from County again I asked
attorney endress to come up with me
because he actually did the litigation
on the issue I'm about to raise point
out the chief pointed out um the issue
of tree Tri um court ordered mandated uh
treatment for um addiction issues uh and
I tie this into the Bale statute because
there's a direct reference in this title
I'm about to tell you under
17213 which is under the New Hampshire
substitute disorder system statute um
there is a mechanism for the courts to
uh refer an individual to Health and
Human Services for evaluation and
recommended treatment um we tried to do
that in a recent case uh individual was
clearly a substance abuse user uh the
judge even commented from the bench that
it was clear um yet uh for some reason
uh the court declined to make that
referral over to Health and Human
Services um without going into details
of that specific
case the part
of 17213 that ties into bail is that if
the person is made that referral goes
into the treatment the court May Rel
leas the person conditionally for
treatment at any alcohol drug abuse
Clinic certified facility mental health
clinic or Center or other appropriate
sources of care so there's already a
mechanism for individuals who have a
demonstrated substance abuse uh issue to
be released pre-trial even if they're
being detained for substance abuse
treatment uh now the difficulty and I'll
defer to attorney Anders to elaborate on
this because he had the actual
discussions with HHS it's my
understanding that HHS has no has no
internal process to process that
individual if the court makes a referral
um and uh I I see that as uh a real
stopping point um it's an Avenue that's
available but it's one that's not
executable it's available by Statute but
not executable by uh by the uh by the
organization um I don't know if attorney
Enders wants to elaborate a little on
that and by that you mean no drug
screening no ability to conduct drug
screening that type of thing the the
statute self and again this is
17213 paragraph 2 actually says when a
person is indicted for a felony or is
awaiting the action of the grand jury on
any felony or is charged with a
misdemeanor and question as to the drug
or alcohol dependency of the person is
raised by either party any justice of
the Superior or Circuit Court having
jurisdiction over the matter May after
hearing order such person to be examined
in accordance with the instructions of
the commissioner to determine whether
said person is drug or alcohol dependent
the commissioner shall report the
results of the examination and his
findings to the court and writing and
the commissioner there's the
commissioner of
DHHS the the next paragraph paragraph
three reads if a person examined
pursuant to the provisions of paragraph
2 is found to be drug or alcohol
dependent the Superior Court having
jurisdiction over the criminal action
May after hearing without regard to the
result of the Criminal action issue an
order requiring the person to accept
treatment at a certified substance abuse
treatment facility when an opening
becomes available during treatment no
further action shall be taken in respect
to the original charges made against
such person unless otherwise ordered by
the court the court May release the
person conditionally for treatment at
any alcohol drug abuse Clinic certified
facility mental health clinic or Center
or other appropriate sources of care um
I had as attorney Halon said filed
asking that someone be evaluated and
called DHHS and said is there anything
I'm supposed to put in this order and
they essentially told me we don't do
this um I explained well the statute
might think differently and they told me
I was reading the statute wrong and I
said you know you might want to take a
look at it and they're like oh it does
say that but we don't have a process in
place for this
so
again the statute exists that allows you
to essentially pause a criminal case and
order a defendant into substance abuse
treatment through DHHS whether in
reality you can do that or not is I
think a different question the role of
DHHS would be simply to screen and and
tell the court whether the person indeed
did suffer from a legitimate mental
health or so they could theoretically
easily farm that out they don't
necessarily need to build a an
infrastructure of their own to do it is
that not the case or at least sound
reasonable
it certainly strikes me that the statute
anticipates the commissioner ordering
this person to be evaluated and then the
commissioner reporting back to the court
on the results of that evaluation yeah
um how long ago did you encounter this
months and uh the difficulty is I was
told we might be able to we would tell
the person to get an appointment
and I explained we might be dealing with
a mentally ill homeless person who's
unlikely to follow through without
appointment which is why we would be
asally why the person's perhaps in the
criminal justice system to begin with
and uh interesting okay thank you we'll
look there certainly is a statute that
exists yeah it seems like the maybe
perhaps direction to the DHHS that they
order said person report to a hospital
or wherever where such screening could
be carried out well they would make that
recommendation to the court the court
would make the order I meant for the
screening portion of right yes yeah and
if they have Medicare then the hospital
could build Medicare and that wouldn't
yeah right we'll look into that thingk
you did you have
something okay and I the last point I
would make is that the new
superintendent the Valley Street the
house Corrections down in Valley Street
was a former superintendent in maram
County he's acutely aware of the uh
programs that he started in maram County
uh that he's now trying to start down in
Valley Street uh I would and I would
recommend that uh the committee consider
sending an invitation to both of those
superintendents uh to see how they've
established those programs uh uh how how
they work it with baale and release um
those invitations have already been
extended we look forward to hearing from
them thank you thank you both we
appreciate it and before anyone else
today
what oh you had a question I me people
in the
time